thank you for that I first want to tell
you look I am so envious of you I I
really am I I had spent more time as a
student both in graduate school and as
an undergrad understanding that the
conversations I have that this seemed
really broad can actually have an impact
in the real world in this moment in time
with your generation where you can
actually marry the big think with the
ideas with legs you're in a really
special position and you're at a time in
history where technology's on your side
and and so it really is incredible to me
that a small idea can have legs and run
around the world in ways that we could
never imagine I was just talking to a
group of students just now who are
looking at the issue of European Muslims
and integration assimilation and the
baggage that goes with what's happening
in Europe right now and I asked them to
look at a piece of the new york times
magazine from a couple of months ago
that i'm going to ask you to look at as
well called digital diplomacy and i cant
rember the author but it was written
about two people one is Alec Ross our
OSS who was Secretary Clinton senior
adviser of innovation and Jared Cohen
who is 28 years old as written two books
is now left the State Department and it
started a idea do tank at Google and I
asked you to look at what they're doing
because its 21st century straight craft
its technology it talks about what I've
just said how do you take how do you
think about diplomacy in a new world and
a new and in a new way using technology
the reason why I'm starting with that to
answer this question is because the
things that you're doing in the
classroom can actually make a difference
to a policy maker if you brand it
correctly if you teach me how to
understand it in a new way to make it
bite size and easier for me not to dumb
it down but for me to understand that
when you're looking at the big questions
and the trends that are out there if all
you do and I be I'm being really
respectful about the importance of
learning how to write how to think and
how to analyze you have to write papers
you have to do them really well and you
have to learn how to express yourself
absolute
but how do you translate those amazing
ideas that you get the a on from your
professor into real deal stuff so
somebody the State Department of the NSC
or the Department of Education can go oh
my god had not thought about that how do
I move it forward that's what he means
by ideas with legs so take your broad
idea bring it down to a place where I
can understand it as a policy maker and
in a way that I can say okay got it here
are the partners I need to use to do
this I'm going to use the strength of
the US government to could do that
convening and that facilitating and
being the intellectual partner with the
idea that you have and move it forward
when I think about some of the coolest
places that that's happening it's not in
the government space but who here has
not heard of Ted right we're trying to
do a TED generation change for this
generation to get the best ideas of
young Muslims from around the world into
a place where they can take those ideas
and take it globally so you're taking
the very cool amazing big thinkers
you're bringing it down to an 18 minute
speech you're making it easily for me to
understand how to move it forward that's
what I need you to do in the classroom
so that's the best way I can think about
to answer that question